since her debut in 1996 Lara Croft
reigns as the undisputed queen of gaming
she has discovered the entrances of lost
cities scaled insurmountable peaks
unraveled mysteries of the past and
captured the hearts of fans the world
over her incredible impact on gaming pop
culture and entertainment could not have
been predicted and 20 years later Lara
Croft remains a true icon of the
industry Tomb Raider is one of the most
successful and longest-running video
game franchises including novels comics
magazines and has spawned countless toys
and merchandise Lara Croft has appeared
in music videos and recently Karen O
lead singer of ye is created an original
song used in rise of the Tomb Raider
Lara Croft also holds more Guinness
World Records than any other gaming
character including the most successful
video game heroine the franchise has won
hundreds of awards and continues to have
a profound effect on the gaming industry
and its players I was a III back when
Tomb Raider launched that was a big
pivotal moment for a lot of us in the
game industry
everything changed a 3d game with this
cool character and like this crazy
environment you could go everywhere and
touch everything was kind of like what
kind of evolution on steroids then she
felt fluid and she could run and jump
and really interact with the environment
an amazing accomplishment Oh dr. mole
Toledano semen et Naruto yatta he Johnny
risk there ha ha ha joke anonymous she's
been around forever and she's probably
one of the most popular female
characters just amazing to grow up with
tomb raiders part of my life I love LA
club she's the most badass character
ever lara mate video games part of our
daily lifestyle part of our culture then
just climb up the plane there how do I
climb just up just because it's a
totally different style of game it was a
first time I think I never seen a female
lead character she's incredibly
intelligent and she's also just like
unabashedly sexy you can be both I love
to see not only that she could fight but
that you know she had integrity and
determination Sam listen I'm gonna get
you after that Lara Croft is not just a
group of pixels to me she taught me how
to be persistent and get what I really
want Lara Croft is not real but she was
pretty real to me when I was even I just
know her there like so many people just
involving themselves in her world and
iterating on it with cosplay your
fanfiction her can turn not everybody
understand why we cosplay but Lara Croft
gave us something to bond over the two
reddit community in particular super
supportive they're like family to me
while you brought us all together thank
you so much in addition to thousands of
cosplayers around the world
multiple Hollywood stars have played the
role of Lara Croft the original tomb
Raider movie edit sequel starred
Angelina Jolie and are among the most
successful video game adaptations of all
time
Camilla Luddington of Grey's Anatomy
Fame has redefined the role for the
modern video games an Academy
award-winning actress Alicia vikander
will star in the upcoming movie Tomb
Raider I mean I grew up loving this
and I played the game when I was a kid
now I remember the scene where you got
to wear the this jungle clearing and his
t-rex comes around the corner I never
experienced anything like that video
game before where something really
really scared me I knew then that I want
to work in video games Lara Croft has
inspired me to take more risks despite
the fear at every step these games maybe
want to go outside to experiment you
know to be more adventurous Laura never
fails to make me smile or make me feel
empowered our Croft is really a part of
my life and I think it will always be
Tomb Raider forever we become who I
meant to be congratulations for our crop
congratulations lower crust
congratulations congratulations
congratulations congratulations Lara
Croft
20 years of an icon 20 years 20 years 20
years 20 years of an icon maintain you
stay calm don't see roll out a stone 18
in our regulations now across 20 years
of nitin congratulations
Lara Croft 20 years of an icon
the divine sorcerer has to be there
you